the best suggestion I've had in the last
year the daily routine of an Aztec high
priest was the best suggestion so we'll
come to this side first thing you're
putting the lights on so I could hold
people accountable if the lights are
down usually some idiot guide the back
is like oh it's my time to just shout
sex and crude things but now the lights
are on you feel more self-conscious so
guys over here what you want to hear a
rap about so we'll see I just said that
guys shouting sex just because you add
in space to it doesn't make it I mean it
merely it is a great suggestion
but sex in space are you involved with
NASA no no would you like to be purely
for that just lie here and it'd be maybe
I don't know anyway but sex in space the
kids that didn't make it in Willy Wonka
fantastic suggestion I just put my hand
up because it's a real good one
Wow the kids that didn't make it in
Willy Wonka it's sex in space let's come
to people at the back of the room you
guys yeah Where's Waldo
it's kind of a boring suggestion I hate
to be I'm fine I'll take it people I
thought you were gonna be with me like
yeah it does suck but no you were all
like oh we kind of wanted that sex in
space the kids that didn't make it Willy
Wonka Where's Waldo there's a TSA reform
in favor of making it more stringent
immoral acts there's definitely a 50/50
split so what's your views on TSA how
should we reform it it's up to me well I
ask you the question you're allowed to I
don't a silence you I'm interested if
you could change one thing about TSA
what would be no TSA all right Osama
what's wrong with you
okay so sex in space the kids that
didn't make it in Willy Wonka Where's
Waldo TSA reform this side of the room
you've only really got one suggestion to
give because they all stole all of yours
and let's see if we can crowdsource a
really good one let's go get a few and
then pick the best yeah Bruno that is
that prune
yeah it's it's it's it's what jail wine
it is and you make it by you put like
anything that's kind of fermentable
sugar in a sock in the back of a toilet
system right well like you know no don't
make out like I've been inside I've not
I've not done hard time no other face
like this gosh pruno i mean that is a
better suggestion than anyone here is
going to give okay pruno prison sex
Where's Waldo TSA reform and the kids
that didn't make it in no sorry not
princess I've got that on the brain now
you just make me think about it sex in
space yeah it's because a week ago
someone suggested prison sex so that's
that's why I'm I'm thinking about that
now I'm just wondering yeah that's cool
okay cool right now I've got my Freudian
slip out of the way this lovely people
of the comedy magic club to close out
the show a fun little thing called a
freestyle rap that has a rap made up on
the spot based entirely on you say whoa
like I don't think clearly that's what
was being set up right I wasn't gonna go
okay your suggestions are these five
things goodnight and goodbye have a no
it's good I'm gonna turn them into a
beautiful song it's it's gonna be
amazing it's not prepared it's not
scripted don't worry it won't be
anywhere near as bad as we're expecting
it to be you seem so unconvinced that's
okay let's let's drop that beat good sir
[Music]
it's a good one as well it's got a nice
little kind of
you can see me I'm Charlie pocket it's
an invitation to one out of six because
of Costas gloop he can't resist he just
leaves his lips oh yes your when he sees
a war fall even though Willy Wonka
doesn't invite him he just says I'm
gonna go and dive in he's a real portly
dude a fat German kid stuck in a tube
she was like oh yeah this isn't hard
Violet Beauregarde
you cheat shoot that gun so she got so
big she's blue Pig and then you had
another guy we can agree American
it wasn't like Where's Waldo attentively
said
in the UK we have a wall though we say
Wally walls oh now you all know the page
what we like he's always hiding with the
red and white stripes grind him down try
and have a look wash down every page is
exactly the same I can't find him well
who's to blame
are you guys surprised you're the worst
of all no you will be illustrate you
just drew him small you've hit em away
what a bad job the yellow a black stripe
guy and the dog always see him again and
again the tail of the dog looking like a
candy cane now there's one more thing
that slipped our brain what was the last
address who needs to do did we did that
one left do we do the hardcore PC gaming
what we aiming this guy he loves
hardcore gaming I go on Twitch and I
play Starcraft in Korea you're gonna see
lol League of Legends
I can't watch with all the great teams
playing on a plasma screen he's played
so much that it's hard to think you
dehydrate when you're playing you don't
think what a bunch of losers they
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]